But when I'm writing a report, there is 100% of vulnerability, right?
Yeah.
And so giving that data out to AI is a little bit tricky.
But man, I benchmarked it against these local models, and it's bad.
It was bad.
And so I don't know.
Here's a trick for you.
What are your thoughts on that?
How do I fix that?
The architecture is you need an obfuscation bot.
Basically, the local model is the obfuscation bot and then the cloud model.
Jason, that's genius.
That is freaking dis...
I'm sorry, Richard.
I should turn my mic down.
I know, Jason, that's such a good idea.
Why did I not think of that?
Son of a bitch.
Redact the domain, redact.
Best part of hacking when you can just, you know, critical thing, right?
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I think fourth time now.
Yeah, for sure.
I'm excited.
And we got a good lineup today.
I think you're really the guy to talk to about the stuff that I've got at the doc.
And I was watching your red, blue and purple AI talk, and it really got my brain spinning a little bit on what I'm calling these micro agents, or agents with a very, very narrow specific purpose within hacking.
And in the talk, you mentioned a couple things like acquisition finder GPT and subdomain doctor, which I thought were really cool applications.
And so I kind of want to double click a little bit into those, talk about how those are working, and then also brainstorm a little bit live on the pod here about what kind of micro agents we could build that might help with the with the hacking process.
Yeah, absolutely.
So I think the precursor to this episode was, you know, you and you and you and Joel had been talking about AI in one of the episodes.
And I hit you up and I'm like, Hey, like, I'm doing a lot of this stuff for red teaming, pen testing and bug bounty.
And so, yeah, so I was like, let's let's chat about it.
And then I've been doing this talk called red, blue, purple AI for quite a while.
Now, the talk is how to apply AI, specifically LLMs, because that's what we have right now, you know, in the consumer space to all types of offensive security problems, but also defensive and purple teaming and stuff.
But in the red portion of that talk that I gave, you know, a couple of the ones I talked about are applications that are very pointed towards bug bounty people.
Right. And so love to see it.
So, you know, what what I did was I took my methodology for, you know, wide scale recon and and for application hacking.
And I was like, OK, what parts of these could an LLM help with them?
You know, a couple of the first ones that just fell out were the ones you talked about. Right.
So so because of the training data set of pretty much all of the models and it's so in depth and the transformer architecture, basically, it has this knowledge base of, you know, pretty much every press release that's been released.
Every article that's been released, you know, a lot of scraping of Web data, a lot of scraping of business analytics sites and stuff like that.
And so for the recon one for the acquisitions, I just started with using ChatGPT.
That was the first thing I did. And so I started asking ChatGPT recon questions like what are the other acquisitions of Tesla? Right.
And so what happened was, to my surprise, you know, normally my source for that, my source of truth is Crunchbase.
Crunchbase is a business aggregation site and they collect information about different businesses for competitive analysis.
And so when I asked GPT and this was back in GPT 3.5 days, when I asked GPT 3.5, it gave me two acquisitions that I had never seen anywhere else.
And I was like, oh, yeah, at first I was like, oh, these must be hallucinations.
And so I go look up. They were not hallucinations. They were they were just not big enough acquisitions to make a site like Crunchbase, you know, monitor them.
And so there are like subsections of acquisitions that, you know, the story I like to tell in the class is that is that one of them was like at one point Tesla decided that they needed to be their own insurance carrier.
And so instead of build out that arm themselves, they they went out and purchased a small insurance carrier to start with, which includes staff.
And it was called something else and they acquired them fully. But but that didn't make like a Crunchbase. Right.
That's not like a big enough splash with, you know, I guess, newsworthy. I don't know what the criteria is. Right.
But we found it through GPT and one other method and they were fully owned by Tesla and we managed to find some bugs on them that led towards the Tesla bounty.
So that's that's one instance of like how that acquisition bot helped.
OK, OK. So, you know, watching the watching the video and seeing you use it, I think these are these are custom GPT is built into ChatGPT. Right.
And I think that's cool. And actually, I think it's a lot more powerful than I expected because it can actually, you know, reference specific sites and research stuff, which is cool.
And I think that's a great way to to pocket.
But I'm wondering, you know, like what I'm envisioning for these micro agents is like very specific, you know, acquisition, finder GPT.
I got in a command line tool and then I can see, you know, how that you know, what it's thinking, how you know, what steps it's taking to get the data, you know, that sort of thing.
And I just pop it off and then I get like an output in a in a, you know, TXT file or whatever in my notes file.
So like if you were going to take this and you were going to build it more into like a command line application or something like that, you know, what do you think that would look like?
Or do you think ChatGPT is really the right fit for for this specific one?
So for this specific one, I think it's absolutely rife to be API.
And in fact, like most of the stuff that I build ends up as an API. Right.
So to to a local server and then a script calls the GPT API.
The reason that I showed ChatGPT in my slides is because it's easiest for people to consume from a talk point of view.
But my actual stuff is all API calls to stronger models.
Stronger models and I can use different models. I don't have to use the open ecosystem.
I could use Claude. I could use whatever. I could, you know, shoot it off to four or five different AIs and then use one A.I. to, you know, stitch it together into a concrete answer and then give that as my notes.
So, yeah. So you can use, you know, Python, go whatever you want and just instrument the ChatGP API.
The one thing I want to stress here, though, is that I feel like a lot of technical people really kind of crap a little bit on the prompt engineering that makes some of these things really good. Right.
And so even when you're building an agent, it's not because it's an agent and the architecture is agentic that it makes a system good.
It is all prompt engineering that makes these micro bots good. All of it. It's all prompt engineering in every single step.
And so I think because that's a lot of natural language work and there's research that goes into that, that people just kind of like gloss over it.
The acquisition spot has a very rigid struck. In fact, I went over it in the talk.
Like I have to tell it what it does. I have to give it related research terms. I have to. There's a methodology for prompting that's really important.
And it's like it feels a little bit like a pseudoscience. Right. But then, you know, there is actual science to it.
I think like one of the ones you covered in the talk was like, all right, you know, you're high on salts or something like that.
And I'm like, really, is that like, is that what you have to say to these things that gives it and, you know, you cited some very specific statistic.
It's like, you know, a 2% boost or something like that across some of these together, which is, which is, you know, substantive for sure.
Yeah. Yeah. So that's, that's the section called weird machine tricks, I call it. And so there are a bunch of weird machine tricks to get to get LLMs to operate in different ways.
I'll give another one. Right. So, so when you have an, when you have a, you know, cloud based LLM like open AI or Claude or perplexity or something like that, and you want it and you give it a query, right?
You can tell it in the prompting to use its search tool if it has a search tool available to it, but it will not always use that.
Search tool. Like there is no way for you to force it to use the search. If it feels like it has the context it needs to answer the question inside of the training data, it will not use the search or it will use selective search.
It will not use the sites that you reference. And so one of the weird machine tricks is, uh, is called adding urgency. And so you have to add urgency to that statement when you tell it, Hey, I want you to specifically search this site.
Like, Hey, the world is going to end or people will die or like crazy shit like that. And I learned this. Yeah. And I learned this in a, um, another class with, uh, another person. I went to a gaming security conference where I was, did that talk. And he was like, Hey, the, the way I get the tools to force to use is adding urgency to that.
And I was like, Hey, I'm going to go to the next level. And I was like, Hey, I'm going to go to the next level. And I'm going to go to the next level.
And I'm going to go to the next level. And I'm going to go to the next level. And I'm going to go to the next level.
And I'm going to go to the next level. And I'm going to go to the next level. And I'm going to go to the next level. And I'm going to go to the next level.
And I'm going to go to the next level. And I'm going to go to the next level.
And I'm going to go to the next level. And I'm going to go to the next level. And I'm going to go to the next level.
So that's why I'm using it. And it's just easy for me to spin this stuff up. And it's really interesting.
It's a new thing to play with. So yeah.
I'm really excited to get your thoughts on Shift. But I do want to click into a couple of these, more of these GPTs and kind of brainstorm around the microagents.
So you've got Subdomain Doctor, which essentially looks at a list of subdomains and outputs some probabilistic subdomains, which we were sort of doing a little bit.
We were implementing back when I was in the recon game. We were using machine learning to sort of extrapolate on these lists of domains that we would see.
So I think this is a really natural use case. I've seen that one before. I love Nuclei Doctor, where it's very easily making Nuclei templates for all these things.
Yeah. But what I was envisioning is agents for specific technical tasks. And I think if we could just create sort of like a framework where this agent has the ability to just modify and tweak an HTTP request in a tool to just send it and get the response.
Yeah. And then we could say something like this. OK, you know, here's this this HTTP request. This specific parameter is, you know, has a restriction on the domain it can redirect to, you know, fuzz this in every way possible that you can figure out to try to make it hit a domain that is not this domain.
Right. And just give it that very, very specific niche task. You know, its input location should be very small and its output.
You know, the part of the response that it's paying attention to should be very small, you know, just the location header or whatever.
Yeah. And and I think, you know, if we give it to that, I'd be really excited to see what kind of stuff the AI comes up with.
Oh, yeah. So I mean, what do you think is the best way to implement something like that?
OK, so so I mean, you're getting into kind of what I would say, like it kind of the cutting edge of, you know, like web fuzzing, you know, applications of AI. Right.
So so there are I would say right now there's probably about 15 companies trying to tackle this problem right now and a whole bunch of individuals as well building agenting systems to do web hacking, basically.
Mm hmm. And so what you have normally is most people trying to build a holistic kind of system to find all web bugs.
But you're talking about it like a micro custom agent that is human in the loop. Right. Right.
And so, yeah, I mean, it's all in the prompt engineering for that problem. Right.
And so the way I want it to work in the way I work a lot these days is actually voice dictation to my computer through my mic.
Yeah, I saw that you did that in the presentation live. I thought that was pretty cool. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And so and so really what I would need is like a, you know, like a way to input into Kyto or into Burp or something like that, that is custom context and then attach it to a vulnerability class bot and a fuzzer. Right.
And so if I wasn't going to use the interception proxy to actually send the web request, right, we could use something like puppeteer playwright or something like that, which most people are using.
So not a lot of people are actually using the interception proxies to send the traffic and analyze it. Most like people who are working on the DEF CON teams that are doing the AICC competition, which I wanted to expose to the people on the pod.
But they're using puppeteer playwright to instrument web hacking techniques.
Okay. So so there that's a that seems like a little bit of a higher layer of abstraction there. And I'm wondering why they're going that route because, you know, HTTP is just text. Right.
You know, it's just in a lot of these problems like like Daniel Meisler, you know, talks about is getting everything to be a world of text. Right.
Yeah. Where where the LALIMS can play with it and parse it and stuff like that. And I think HTTP is already text.
Yeah. So I feel like it should be really simple to create something where we give it an HTTP request and, you know, maybe there's a lot of tokens. Right.
You know, because HTTP requests have massive tokens. It's fine. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. But but and then, you know, it we just enable it to just, you know, string replace a specific, you know, maybe give it a string replace tool and a and an HTTP send tool.
And then we just kind of let it brain and watch the the, you know, chain of thought and watch the the the response, the request and the response.
Like, I don't know, am I oversimplifying the problem here? Is there is there more to it? That should be pretty simple. Right. Yeah. That's easy. That's easy to do. So all of my not doing this right now.
Yeah. All of my not doing this right now. So I sent you the architecture for what I'm building right now.
I'm not crazy. I'm not sharing it. But in that section is the the web fuzzers. Right. And so that would be a sub component agent of a web fuzzer.
And so you have to build some prompt engineering in there to do the match and replace. And you have to rig it up to Kyto, which I'm sure you're using. Right. Yeah.
And and to do the and to do the web sending. But, yeah, it's not a hard problem at all. Right.
I think the institutional knowledge of like basically the training data set for whatever A.I. you're going to use to build those bypasses or to contextually attack a certain vulnerability has some prompt engineering built into it that I think that I've noticed that you can't just ask it a general question.
Sometimes it'll give you kind of trash answers. You have to be very specific with the types of tricks you want it to perform sometimes in the prompt engineering.
So that agent has to have some system prompting to it.
So we need to ingest. I think Reza was talking about this with me the other day.
We need to ingest like, you know, world class documentation on these specific types of vulnerabilities and stuff like that.
Let me give you an example here. So, OK, so when you were talking the attention mechanism inside of LLMs is one of the most kind of like key parts to what makes LLMs what they are today.
And what the attention mechanism does is it takes a token. But in our case, let's just talk about a word. Right.
It takes a word and it updates its context in a 4D space and it shifts your next token generation into that 4D space based on every preceding word, basically.
And so when you feed into it really good context, like a world class research document on bypassing filters for SSRF and other things, what that does is it narrows the output focus of the LLM to the best possible research.
And so that's one of the prompt engineering tricks that you can do is inside of the prompt engineering.
What I do is very it's like SEO. Right. So when you have a website, you have a whole bunch of like SEO keyword terms that you seed everywhere so that search engines, you know, find your site like Google.
Find your site like Google and stuff like that. Yeah. I seed my system prompts with very technical words that shift the 4D space narrower to world class kind of output.
And so that's that's what you have to do. It's crazy, man. That's some brainy shit.
Every time I try to think about like four dimensional, you know, like implications of this sort of thing, I just my brain just starts like the only reason the only way I found that I can really grasp that sort of thing is obviously we live in a three dimensional reality.
Right. And then, you know, we've got the fourth dimension of like time, you know, and I'm like, how do I map all of that?
It's crazy, man. So if you want like a visual representation of the attention mechanism, there's a great video by three blue one brown and and he has a whole series on how how transformers work.
But specifically his video on the attention mechanism really opened my mind in how to think about prompt engineering to better narrow the space for, you know, world class output for these bots.
That's awesome, man. I'm definitely going to check that one out afterwards. We'll link that down in the description as well.
All right. So we got so let's brainstorm a little bit on these micro agents, because I think what I think it should be pretty easy to spin off sort of like a and I'm probably oversimplifying the problem, but I think it should be pretty simple once we get, you know, the HTTP stuff in place and then we get the we get this, you know, match and replace stuff in place.
It should be pretty easy to implement this thing. So I'm thinking, you know, we've got the open redirect stuff. Another one that I think would be really good is WAF bypasses because that just that thing just it takes so much freaking time and it's so frustrating.
And if I could just but the techniques are pretty, pretty simple, you know, mix up some encoding, you know, work from character to character and figure out which character is triggering the, you know, the laugh and then kind of go on from there.
Yeah, I think that would be a pretty good one. Yeah, so you can use at least what I've used is backslash powered scanner.
So the the idea behind backslash powered scanner is send, you know, a character that is a control character or a special character of some sort, see how the application reacts and then send it again.
But escaped, you know, because escaping in the Linux land, you know, means that it wouldn't carry its special character context on the command line and then seeing if there's any difference in the response. Right.
And so that same idea can be used in AI, right? Give it a list of special characters that triggers the laugh.
The condition that the laugh usually triggers on. Is it a 404? Is it a longer page load? Is whatever it is, right?
Is it a special error page? Is it the cloud flare 403? You know, whatever. Right.
And then and then have something parse the response. Now, what you're missing here is you do need either automation like, you know, like some type of response automation grepper or, you know, an agent to basically parse the response.
Yeah. And it's going to be hella slow if you make it parse the whole response every time and think like, is this the, you know, cloud flare 403? Right.
Yeah. So we need to say we should come about it a little bit more intelligently and we should say, OK, you know, here's when I give it the context for the situation, I should say, OK, you know, the cloud flare 403, you know, is the is the situation.
Yeah. Returns the status code. It has this icon. It usually has this text.
Yeah. You know, it has these colors. Like if you want to get into like image recognition, it looks like this. You could do all of that.
I wonder if we could even ask it to, you know, this is where Rezo starts getting uncomfortable with me when I'm brainstorming with him.
He's like, Justin, you know, having AIs run the code is is not great. But I'm thinking like, all right, have it generate some code that it then runs to say, you know, Boolean, true or false.
And true or false. Is this a a actual, you know, for a three page or is this something different? Right.
Yeah. Yeah. And so, you know, it could be as simple as the status code, which would be easy to extract.
But it could also be like, all right, does this regex hit in like, you know, that sort of thing.
And if we enable them to use those tools like, you know, even if you just enabled regex, that should be plenty. Right.
Yeah, for sure. I mean, a lot of that you can do inside of the interception proxy.
Some of it you can't do. You can get more advanced with the AI with like an AI parser. But but yeah, I mean, it should be able to instrument all of that pretty, pretty easily. Yeah.
All right. What other ones we got? I had I had like a path traversal fuzzer. I think that would be pretty cool if you could figure out a way to like that one would be more complicated.
Right. Is like how do you determine what is like what should be causing a traversal and what shouldn't be causing a traversal and when that occurs.
But that that one I think could drop some crits.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think that anything that has to do with manipulate manipulating URLs like SSRF and path traversal and, you know, or paths.
It is it is a little bit harder in the response matching and the regex and understanding.
But I mean, you can hook it up to, you know, collaborator type server. Right. To parse the responses that you get back.
The important thing is when you're building the fuzzing bots, each individual request has to have a unique key associated to it.
So you can tie it back to which fuzzing request did it because in my fuzzers they're building hundreds of attack strings to try to bypass filters, WAFs, everything. Right.
So my XSS fuzzer will build hundreds of attacks and each one has to be unique so I can tell, you know, which bypass worked and the response parser has to tell me, you know, like, OK, number 72 worked out of this list.
Yeah, we could probably just hash the request, save that hash and then, you know, save a list of their requests or, you know, just build it into logic to, you know, write off the request whenever it works.
I'm used to. So I came from back in the day writing Web Inspect checks, which is a dynamic scanner a long, long time ago.
And I mean, I guess it still exists today, but I don't know who owns it.
But yeah, that I mean, the way we did it was, you know, like we're like basically the, you know, access payload when it was an alert or something like that would be a unique string.
So we could we could keep back on that.
Oh, nice. Yeah, that works.
All right. The last one last one I had that I'm jazzed about and I, you know, Jason, I I'm sorry for prodding you so much about all this because I know I know you sent over that diagram and, you know, I think we were both sort of on the same brainwave, but you were much further.
Yeah, you were much farther down the path than I was.
So now I'm here. I'm like, so, you know, you've been working on this for the past couple of months.
We just like give me all your secrets. Yeah, that's fine.
But the one that that I'm pretty jazzed about right now is is an automatic fix bypass.
Right. Because like so whenever we report a vuln and this is fluid specifically work well for, I think, on authenticated vulnerabilities, I think it would be awesome to be able to like give the AI access to your platform account, your bug crowd account, your hack one account and say, all right, here's the report.
Yep.
Whenever this thing goes resolved or, you know, and or whatever, try to bypass it. And like for me, I know when I report something, I'm like, you know, I bet they're going to fix it like this. And I bet that's going to be vulnerable.
So what I do is I go in my calendar and I like put in an item and it says check this report on this date. And then I get to inevitably I get to that date and they still haven't fixed it. And I, and then I push it again another month or whatever.
But then it would be really cool if I could just offload that whole process onto the AI and tell it in advance. Okay, this is what they're probably going to do to fix it. Try this, try this, try this, try this. Once the fix comes up and you know, then then ping me.
Yeah. Like, wouldn't that be sick?
That I'm literally doing that right now.
Yeah. So, so email automation is part of it to give me the updates and you know, like discord notifications, stuff like that. But the regression testing, I call it regression testing bot. Right. And it has my, it has that exact stuff, right. It's my institutional knowledge of most developers fix bugs.
Because we don't have any, we don't have any input on how they fix it. Right. Like, I mean, we could tell them, we could give them remediation, but that's usually not our place in the bug bounty world. More in the pen test and consulting world it is. But normally they fix it with, you know, like, let's take a cross site scripting attack. Right. They fix it with a horrible regex, right.
Yeah. To like block, you know, the attack payload or the, you know, like, you know, some sort of the payload or whatever the attack string, or they put in some laugh rule. Right. And so, because you have been testing for, you know, what, like 10 years, 20 years now or something like that, you have all this institutional knowledge of how to break those very simple things.
Right. And so, because you have been testing for, you know, what, like 10 years, 20 years now or something like that, you have all this institutional knowledge of how to break those very simple things.
And so, you have to break those very simple regexes. And so, you can type that into the system prompt for that agent. And then it will just go back and try those for you or prepare them for you. And then you can go try them. And yeah. So, one of the ones I use that's an example in the talk, I don't know if I gave it at, in that keynote, but I talk about it in the class that I teach, is an actual CBE.
So, there was a JetBrains product I ran into on a web pen test. And so, you know, when you're on a web pen test, or you know, you're on like an external red team, you know, you'll go and search, does this software have any CBEs, right? That's part of your workflow. And it's like, you know, if it has bugs, I'm going to exploit them.
So, it had a CBE that was pretty recent, but had been patched. And it was, you know, basically this version of this JetBrains software that was installed had been patched. But I looked at it and it was like, oh, it was a vulnerability that was associated to Markdown, basically.
And so, this was one of those CBEs where they didn't even give you a tax string. They just said, hey, this product had a vulnerability in this section of the software. It was a vulnerability for cross-site scripting based on Markdown, a Markdown parser.
And so, really, there was only two places in the application that handled Markdown. And so, my regression testing bot, I just fed it that string, the CBE input string. And I said, hey, it says it has a Markdown vulnerability. Here's the section where the Markdown interpreter is. How would you come up with 10 ways to bypass this?
And then I fed it some context on attacking, basically, XSS and Markdowns, which I found via Hacktivity. I found via some pen test presentations that were at cons. I fed it that context. And then some of my own tricks. And it found two bypasses for the CBE in like a publicly, you know, sold JetBrains products.
Wow, dude, that's great. And I think this is also, now that I'm thinking about this, this is a great reason to disclose reports for companies, right?
Like, if you want your vulns to be actually thoroughly regression tested and fixed, then you should disclose the report. Because what's going to happen then is eventually someone is going to come up with this regression tester bot like yours, right?
And they're just going to apply them against all of the Hacktivity.
And just raking the vulns.
You want to know what the bypasses were?
Yeah, hit me, man.
Okay, so the normal injection was adding an image tag with JavaScript in it, right?
Inside Markdown, right?
The two breaks were one, break the Markdown into three lines and add null characters in the separating line between the attack.
And then it will reform the attack string past the regex.
That worked.
Wow.
And then data encoding the payload in base64.
Both worked.
Data encoding the what part of the payload?
The JavaScript.
The JavaScript, yeah.
That's whack, dude.
Yeah, yeah.
Because that's not, the problem isn't the actual JavaScript content.
The problem is, you know, the onload handler or the on error handler.
Wow.
Yeah.
That was not a great fix then.
Yeah, yeah.
No, no.
It was literally a regex fix to the first thing, right?
So anything that passed the original attack string regex worked.
Nuts, man.
That's nuts.
All right.
Cool, man.
Well, I won't, you know, juice you for any more information about all that.
But it's very exciting.
I think up until this point, I've very much been a, you know, in the loop, human in the
loop sort of guy where I'm like, yeah, you know, I think these things can be really helpful
in helping us perform more effectively.
But I think lately I've really been seeing the vision of like, especially these smaller
scale tasks.
Yeah.
It's still human in the loop, but it's like, you know, and then I'm just delegating
this one little piece.
Oh, yeah.
And I think that is really big.
And then, you know, eventually at some point we may be able to, you know, we may be able
to delegate our whole piece of it.
But I think I think it's going to be those small pieces for a really long time.
And I think that I think that that is the power of the agentic architecture, right?
It doesn't it doesn't add anything that like that is super special in the architecture.
What it does is it allows us to let each bot focus on its own little task, which makes
the you know, the context you feed it more powerful and the output you get from it more
powerful.
Because if I just ask a bot, like, how do I hack this website and I give it some HTTP
traffic, right?
That output comes out bad.
And that's what that's most hackers first experience with using an LLM to hack is they're
like, OK, let me feed you this whole page.
And you tell me like that's what they want.
Right.
They want it to be like, oh, you know, hack this website for me.
And that's that's not how it works.
Right.
It's it's like, OK, take let's take the website.
Let's parse it.
Let's identify all the inputs.
Let's then read those contextually for what types of vulnerabilities we think they're going
to be statistically relevant to them.
Then break that down, send them to agents that are specialists in those vulnerabilities
and then somehow execute the HTTP requests and then have an agent parse the response and
then feed it all back to me to do any manual testing.
I need to.
I have three workflows that go on.
Oh, my gosh.
I have the parsing one.
I have the fuzzing one.
And then I have one that feeds me manual testing ones.
So let me ask you this.
How much does this cost?
You know, like if you're using Soda models for all this, it's going to get expensive, I
imagine.
But because that's one of the things we're running into a little bit with Shift is like,
OK, how do I narrow down this massive amount of data that comes in with every single request?
You know, like if I'm just to double click a little bit into how Shift works.
And let me backtrack a little bit.
Shift is a Kaido AI plugin for anybody that haven't heard of it.
You can it's in closed beta.
You can check it out at shiftwaitlist.com.
But essentially, it just integrates AI seamlessly into Kaido so you can use it in your HTTP proxy.
And the way that it works is it takes, you know, all of these different pieces of Kaido state.
Right.
It takes the request, the response, you know, all of your workflows you have defined, your
scope, all of that stuff.
And it builds it into the context and it shoots the context up to the to the AI along with
your query.
And then, you know, it decides out of the set of tools we've given it what actions should
be taken, pushes that back to the proxy.
The proxy takes the actions and then the user's intent is is sort of accomplished there.
Um, and so, yeah, I think I think that sort of that sort of piece of it where you are,
um, taking those those various actions from the AI and in your executing them and and doing
that in a in a recursive way with these smaller agents.
It's big, man.
It is big.
Yeah.
It's and I think shift is going to be like a massive force multiplier for, you know, human
in the loop testing.
And I mean, that's the kind of stuff that I, I output to just a GPT.
But, you know, there's, there's some other things, you know, in there I'll talk to you
offline about some things I think that I should add.
Yeah.
For sure.
Dude, that's great.
Yeah.
Like, man, I always want to, I always want to do brainstorming on the pod, but it is that
it is that, you know, that trade off of like, let's let's serve the community, but let's
validate some of these things for validation purposes.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I do want to get your thoughts on that.
On shift a little bit more like, I guess what, because I'm tempted, we could go in a couple
directions at this point, you know, where shift is currently at is, you know, we can modify
stuff in replay.
We can, which is a Kaido's version of repeater.
You know, we could create automate stuff, which is intruder.
You know, we can create those.
You can do match and replace stuff, which is really cool.
You can forge HTTP QL queries, that sort of thing.
And there's a couple of places we could go.
One, obviously, I think we need to implement the autocomplete, you know, inside the actual,
on the lines, you know, sort of like cursor, right?
Where you just kind of press tab or Copilot and press tab and it just knows what you want.
Definitely going to do that.
But then I'm sort of tossed up.
Do I go the chat route?
Or do I go the route of like, let me integrate some of these micro agents that we've been
talking about directly into the HTTP proxy?
I think the more valuable thing for testers is the micro agents into the proxy, I think.
And you are going to hit, I mean, the more agents you create, the more traffic you have
to parse, right?
So it means that you're going to hit those costs again.
I mean, my personal setup, you have to realize I have transitioned more away from bug bounty into red teaming.
So I still do a lot of web testing.
It's just done on contract.
So, but I'm not testing like every day of the week.
I'm testing, you know, maybe a week on, week off or something like that.
So I only spend like, you know, five, maybe $500 a month or $400 a month on my token usage across all AIs.
Thank you.
I'm glad you came back to that because I got off the wrong track, but that's really interesting.
So you're paying, you're paying.
See, this is, that sounds like a lot to me, right?
$500 a month sounds like a lot, but this is the same sort of problem that you, that we were running into back in the day when people like Eric,
started spending like $2,000 a month on, on like servers and stuff to do mass recon.
Mass automation.
Totally worth it.
Everybody knows that it's worth it now.
Yeah.
You know?
And so I think being early to that is, is big.
500 bucks.
Wow.
That is a little bit more than I expected though.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm, I'm paying for the new, the new model for open AI.
So I just increased my cost for it.
I would say before paying for the new subscription on opening AI, it was probably more than 300.
And then, but yeah, I have, I have.
I have.
So here's something that we didn't talk about is different models benchmark different, benchmark
well at different things.
So yeah.
For anything that's contextual and analysis based, I use the open AI ecosystem for my agents,
right?
For anything that's write me code or generate attack strings that actually I use Claude for.
It's gotta be Claude.
Yeah.
Anything that's search related where I want to use search, I have moved away from the default
plugins in the open AI ecosystem and it moved to perplexity to feed that into the context
window of GPT.
Oh, interesting.
Because it is, has a better search bot.
Yeah.
So I haven't played around with perplexity that much.
Have you, have you, have you used Gemini at all?
What are your thoughts on Gemini?
So Gemini forever burned itself for me when, when I figured out that the training data is partly
from Reddit.
Um, and so, uh, you know, they had that big snafu.
It was publicly what it was like, it was like, Oh, um, like my P my cheese is not sticking
to my pizza.
What do I do?
And someone asked Gemini and Gemini was like, add Elmer's glue to your sauce.
Oh my God.
And so when someone dug into like, where did that come from?
Uh, it turns out it was a Reddit comment like 10 years ago by someone who was trolling.
And that's the closest context the bot could get to pizza sauce needing to be stickier.
Um, and so like, you know, forever that is burned in my mind.
So I haven't given a chance.
I know it has been benchmarking really, really high lately.
Yeah.
I think it has.
And, and, and I think opening eye and Gemini has definitely had its more than it's fair
sure.
I'd say of dumb shit that it said, but I think opening eyes models and, and Claude as well.
I haven't heard as much about Claude, but opening eyes definitely has said some dumb stuff
too.
Yeah.
They all have, I mean, I'm, I need to go back and benchmark, um, Gemini.
I mean, there's, there's so many models, man.
I mean, there's like fast man flashes is quick.
It's quick.
Yeah.
I mean, if you, if you look at like the whole scene of all of the models that are coming
out, there's a great table that I have bookmarked in my presentation, but it's like,
there are over like cloud SAS based models that have had pre or post training for different
specific tasks.
There's 200, 300, you know, out there that you could use.
And then, you know, if you want to make custom stuff in your home, you can use llama, you know,
all the new versions of llama and, um, yeah.
So, but I mean, in general, I'm sticking with open AI and anthropic ecosystems.
Yeah.
Most of the time.
I'm excited for the local stuff to get better, man.
I, you know, we really, we, I tried to benchmark some of the local stuff when I was built, um,
the fabric, uh, right hacker one report fabric, uh, extension.
And, um, and it just, it just wasn't good, man.
It just wasn't good.
But I know that they've, they've released some good stuff.
And, and, you know, maybe if I get a beefier machine with a better GPU, then it might be,
it might be good.
But, um, yeah, I, I, I think that's the next frontier, man.
If we can make everything local or if we can solve that problem where it's like, um, where we can
encrypt the prompt and encrypt the response so that the, the, uh, provider itself of the model doesn't,
doesn't have introspection into that.
Um, but I, I think that that I was listening to a podcast, I think it was Lex Friedman's podcast with,
um, the, the cursor team.
Um, that is a really hard problem to solve.
I think is getting, is mapping that, that, you know, those vectors into an encrypted space, you know,
where it's not introspectable is like, that's going to be a while down the road, I think.
It is, yeah, it is quite a bit away.
Yeah.
I think, I think right now you have to assume that's anything in the training data and anything in the system prompting is subject to, um, being leaked no matter what.
So that's just what you have to assume right now.
Let me ask you this.
What do you think about, um, you know, obviously we've got the soda models, um, and the state of the art models.
And I think they do a great job performing with cybersecurity tasks.
Um, but sometimes they will whine at you for, you know, trying to be a hacker or whatever.
Um, and I've seen some, some, um, sort of custom models built around this, like white rabbit Neo or, or any of those.
And, and I'm, I'm wondering what your thoughts are on like, should there, we, should we actually be building models specifically for, um, security, you know, at a lower level at sort of that AI, uh, model engineering level.
Yeah.
I mean, I would, I would hope that we could get there.
My hope is, but my, my practicality and usage of the tool says that, uh, the big models trained on billions of parameters are just going to have the best context, uh, training data.
And they have always performed the best for me.
Like you were saying, you know, sometimes meta, you can just tell it has that uncanny valley feel to it, right?
Like generic writing style.
It's not very technical sometimes, even when you try to system prompt it well, it just doesn't do as well as the bigger, you know, SAS models.
Or, you know, other models.
And so, uh, a lot of times in my security based prompting, like a couple of my bots that I put out on the store are, I have gotten banned from like the automated systems.
So the GPT ecosystem.
Um, but when you're, when you're building these for your own usage, right, there's a couple of tricks, right?
So first of all, tell it's tell the bot in the system prompting it's working on a CTF.
And since most of the tools you're going to be using.
Um, you're going to be using, so the CTF one works a lot of times.
And since most of the tools you're going to be working on, um, are you're going to be using the API rather than the chat interface, you'll have access to precede a user prompt.
So you have a system prompt and your user prompt, which is usually what you chat to the bot.
Right.
But you can precede, you can hard code in user prompts.
And so, um, what you can do is you can, um, send the API request to the bot or the agent and start off with a prompt, like, Hey, I'm a cybersecurity student doing a CTF.
Will you help me?
Mm-hmm.
And then once the bot responds in the affirmative, that's in your context window.
Um, and then every subsequent, uh, and it, and it replies in the affirmative, every subsequent request, it's more likely to just say, okay, we're going to continue working on this problem.
I love that.
The bot's like, ah, well, I said I'd help them.
I said I'd help them.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Dude, that's, those are great.
Those are great.
Those are great tidbits, man, that, that, that, that will make the difference when we, when we get a little bit deeper into, into developing all this stuff.
Um, so, so I guess coming back around to shift, um, you know, currently we have a way to interact with a decent bit of the pieces of Kaido, um, thinking about implementing the agents.
I think that would be pretty cool.
Um, what, what advice do you have for me on that?
Like I'm, I'm, I'm thinking, you know, what, what way should I implement that?
And that it'll be most helpful, helpful to hackers.
Like, do you think I should implement a, a, um, you know, release like a laugh bypass, uh, uh, bot or something like that?
Or do you think we should try to build it in such a way that each individual person can write their own customized bots?
I think, I think you have to do both, right?
Because there's, there's a couple of custom things that I want to be able to ask my proxy, right?
In the future state of the world, I want to be able to give very specific.
Hold on.
I'm getting my notes ready.
This is great.
In the future, I want to be able to talk to my interception proxy and give it specific context based around, um, what I've noticed from the app already.
Dude, the, the, you say talk using, I don't know if that's just a verbiage, but I mean, is it really important for you to be able to just like speak to it?
I'm a speaking type person.
That's right.
I mean, I've been on the pod four times now.
Right.
So I'm good at talking.
So, um, I mean, but you could, you could type too.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Like I need to be able to give, I need to be able to give the interception proxy, uh, my contextual knowledge in a quick way.
Um, that's very specific to this app.
Right.
I think that there's, there's some stuff like, okay, so what if there's a previous bunch of reports that you have on this and you want to make sure that that context and how, you know, like how it's worked before.
That's a great idea.
That is an excellent idea.
Like what if, what if you know already which libraries on the backend are parsing URLs or something like that?
That's context the bot can use in every fuzzing attack, um, for SSRF or, you know, uh, you know, whatever.
Um, and so me having one interface for automated fuzzers is great and building agents.
That's cool.
That's going to come whether you do it or somebody else.
So that's coming.
That's coming.
Someone's going to build it.
I've built it in the GPT, like ecosystem.
Someone else.
So, but those are super useful.
Um, and they're easier to accomplish, honestly, than, um, this contextual based stuff.
And so I think that you have to have both.
I think that you have to have, uh, you know, like, oh, I'm working on this specific app.
Like what about, okay.
So one of my favorite examples is, um, I don't know, you were at this event.
Do you remember two years ago at the Vegas, um, at the Vegas event?
Um, it was,
We can bleep it if you, uh, yeah.
No, no, it's cool.
I'm not going to release the customer, but there was a hacker one live event in Vegas.
And the customer had, um, the customer had an app that, uh, dealt with, um, telephony,
um, in certain parts of it.
And, uh, and someone figured out that you could call like this API and basically charge the company a bunch of money.
Yeah.
Um, do you remember that bug?
We've actually talked about that bug on the pod before.
Yeah.
That is just legendary attack vector ideation.
And so the, the, like with contextual knowledge like that, when you can talk to your proxy or type to your proxy and be like, cool here, here is actually what the site's meant to do.
It can't parse that from the HTML.
I mean, maybe it could read some text in the description of whatever, but you dictating to the meta knowledge about what the business functions are for the app.
Then it can get even better at finding some esoteric bugs, basically.
Ah, very cool.
Okay.
So I need to be able to have it talk to me and, and talk to it mostly.
Yeah.
And I need to, uh, give it contextual knowledge about the app and I need to be able to ingest reports.
Man.
I really liked that last one.
That last one is super good.
If, if, if we could just say like, all right, you know,
So we, we do it with our pen test reports, right?
Like when we come back for the next year to do an annual pen test or red team, right?
It's like, okay, here's the previous report.
First of all, we need to check all these things to make sure if they're valid or, or they've regressed or there's some kind of bypass.
Um, but also it feeds, you know, our context for the assessment.
Cause we've written down all this information that was very, you know, specific to this engagement.
Yeah.
And it's what most of the pen test companies are rushing to do right now.
They're rushing to build internal systems to parse all of their reports, all of their tips and tricks out of a rag database.
Um, and then be able to build a, you know, assistant to help their red teamers and pen testers.
Most consultancies I know right now are racing to build this.
In fact, I've helped some of them build it themselves.
Yeah. Yeah. The rag stuff is, is really important.
Getting all that vectorized and stuff and understanding what needs to be vectorized and what needs to be actually in the prompt, you know, itself.
Yeah.
Uh, to highlight and inform the AI versus just direct to the AI versus like informing it with, with rag polls.
Um, yeah. It's interesting stuff.
Yeah. And then the, the fuzzers are, you know, are pretty easy.
So you go out and do the kind of research you do, right?
I know when you hack, you spend a lot of time like figuring out the components of how to hack certain things.
Um, and the vulnerability class.
And, you know, the person I see do this really well is, um, is Greg for bug bounty reports explained.
I love it, man. That's why I'm a subscriber dude.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
His data stuff is so good.
That's the same way. I, so like my bug bounty methodologies, all my talks and stuff are based around just like diving deep into research around a couple things at a time and then building a methodology and understanding patterns.
Right. Um, and since I'm an offensive security guy, like makes easy, but your fuzzers, you're going to write the system prompts for those fuzzers for each individual vulnerability with all of your contextual knowledge.
Like what bypasses work these days, which ones don't, what is the workflow for bypassing a WAP versus bypassing a regex?
There's differences sometimes, you know, what is the workflow for, um, using different event calls, you know, like using different functions, you know, like all kinds of stuff.
So you're going to write that into your prompts.
Yeah, for sure.
And let me, let me ask you this.
That makes me, it makes me think of this.
Um, you know, one of the things that I would really like shift to be able to do is, you know, sort of watch your HTTP history or whatever and learn the things that you need to know, like IDs, right?
Like, well, I very much should be able to just like open a JSON, you know, blob or whatever, and, you know, just say, all right, user ID, you know, colon, double quote.
Right. And then I should have it be able to know what user ID I want to come after or give me an option of user IDs.
You know, okay, user A has this user ID, user B has this user ID, or, and just build out that whole, you know, request piece.
And the way we've solved this right now in, in shift is we've got this memory function where you can highlight some text,
and press control shift M and it will take that, you know, piece of free form text and put it in its memory.
And that memory gets fed to the AI whenever you, you know, query.
So you can say, all right, build out this request for me and it will sub in all the requests.
Or you could say, build out this request with user A and it will build out all the requests. Right.
Yeah.
But ideally I would like the AI to identify itself what IDs are important.
Well, and that gets tricky, right? I mean, what are your thoughts on that?
Not too tricky. I mean, have you ever heard of this project called Hunt before that I did?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I have. Of course.
Of course, Jason, we all know you're a legend. Come on. Yes. I've tracked everything you've done since I was a beginner.
So, yeah. So you can take the statistically probable parameters for each individual vulnerability type.
Yes. That's exactly it. Brilliant. I mean, you can, you can put that into the context window and have the AI identify it.
So actually my version, I just implemented that here. And so I have to keep up on, you know, common frameworks of authentication types to understand what the parameter names are.
But I put that into the context window the bot. It auto identifies that stuff for me now.
It's like, okay, so you sent several queries with this user ID, with the user ID parameter or route. And here are the values for that.
Would you like to reuse them, you know, for authentication attacks? And I'm like, yes. And then it'll build me out curl strings.
Or I haven't set it up in a proxy like you guys have. So I use curl to do authentication testing and it'll auto fill those user IDs, the authorization headers, the cookies.
If I need it, it'll build web requests that I can paste in the burp. So it does all of that for me.
That's freaking great. Wow. And is that, is that a command line tool or using GPT for that?
It's the command line tool now. Yes. Yeah. Wow. That, that just integrates you just boom. And then it generates all this stuff.
And then, yeah, the next step I guess would be, you know, getting it ingestible into a proxy.
Yeah. There's still that step of me having to copy and paste, which sucks.
Hey, but you know, it's a lot better than having to build out the request from scratch.
It is. It is a lot better than that. So much better, man. It's so much better, yeah.
One of the game changer things with, with shift for me was just being able to, to copy a piece of JS code, shift space, paste it in and say, build this.
Yeah. And it just, boom. And I'm like, oh my God, I love that. You know? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The parser part, the free form parsing of routes and parameters, I mean, has been really good with AI.
It'll build me an attack map of all routes and parameters for an application. And then if it's, you know, API based or, or something else, you know, if I have like a swagger file or something like that, it can build me all the curl requests I need to test with the authorization header and without the authorization header.
It'll automatically figure out what the schema is for the JSON, which I'm horrible at when I'm like looking at, you know, stuff like that.
Yeah. It's hard. It's hard to get the right indentation.
Yeah. Yeah. The right indentation. It's like, what is, you know, what is top level? What is bottom level? Like, you know, uh, it'll also even guess at, you know, sometimes they don't give you, like they give you the type like integer or whatever, but they don't give you, um, specific like lengths or, you know, what is supposed to be in there.
And, you know, like, uh, it'll guess at those and give me some possible things that I can fill into the payload types, which is fantastically useful. It doesn't sound useful when you say it out loud, but it is fantastically useful when you're actually doing API testing.
Yeah. Um, yeah. So there's all kinds of stuff it can do. And I use it a lot in a suggestion form too, right? Like, like I, you can break it out into sections. What do you know? And what can you prove? And then what can you suggest? Um, and then the suggestion part actually ends up winning a lot of times too, as well.
So, that's awesome. That is, that is some great work, man. Yeah. I think, I think, uh, I'm excited to have that in, in my proxy and I'm going to continue building it out. Yeah. Those are some great ideas. Um, so, so let, let me ask you this as well. So my first little dabble into, into AI was, um, you know, of course, after seeing, uh, Daniel Meisler's fabric thing and being like, ah, you know what, this is, this is, I need this in my life, you know?
Yeah. And, and then building the, um, write hacker one report, um, sort of extension for that. I forget what they're called at this moment, but you know, patterns, patterns. Thank you. That's the term. Um, writing that pattern. And, and that's been really helpful because, you know, H1 has a template that they normally use.
And it's pretty simple. And I just kind of built that out and, and created a workflow in Kaido to just, you know, right click on a request, send it out.
Yeah.
And then just give it a little bit of extra context and boom, it, it generates the report. Um, the problem with that is that it is, it is the, the local models really, uh, you know, we're dealing with something a little bit more sensitive here. Like, I'm, I'm, I'm a little bit less like, uh, you know, the, the AI is seeing all of these requests, you know, it's like, okay, sure. And they see, you know, a thousand requests that don't work for every one request that does have a vulnerability in it. Right. Um, so I'm a little bit less paranoid about that.
But when I'm writing a report, there's 100% of vulnerability, right. You know? And so giving that data out to AI is a little bit, is a little bit tricky. Um, but man, I just, I benchmarked it against these local, these local, um, models and it's, it's, it's bad. Uh, it was bad, you know? And so I don't know.
Here's, here's your thoughts on that. How do I, how do I fix that?
The architecture is you need a obfuscation bot. Basically the local model is the obfuscation bot and then the cloud model. So.
Jason.